on a quelques petits soucis techniqu
rassurez-vous on va y arriver je me
connecte là et comme ça on est ensemble
en direct depuis le ces c'est un petit
pe mais on va y arriver soyez rassuré
est-ce que vous êtes là est-ce que vous
êtes nombreus nombreux ou alors est-ce
qu'on y est pas encore regardez on va
tous ensemble hop alors je me connecte
directement est-ce que mon Léo toi
derrière tu vois un peu du monde sur le
chat ça arrive se connecte ok c'est
génial alors c'est l'aventure parce que
en fait faut savoir qu'au COS on souvent
des problèmes de Wii et il y a un moment
voyez ça ça marche ça marche pas on
galère on galère pas on galère un peu à
partir mais ça y est on y arrive alors
le temps que moi j'arrive et je me
reconnecte jusqu'à vous comme ça on va
être ensemble je vais pouvoir bien
évidemment lire le chat savoir ce que
vous me racontez voilà je vois que vous
êtes là hop voilà c'est parti salut
monsieur Greux salut coucou à tout le
monde bon ça y est on est parti bon
alors comment est-ce que ça va ça y est
je vois un petit peu vos messagees
bonsoir à oui bonsoir 720p oui ben ça ça
va êre tout le problème de la résolution
ici mais on va y arri soyez rassuré hop
là voilà bon allez c'est parti allez on
est ensemble on va parler des produits
de roboroc ensemble il y a des
nouveautés on est en direct au CES on va
aller regarder quelles sont les
nouveautés il y a plein de nouvelles
choses venez avec moi suivez-moi c'est
par ici allez zo on va essayer de se
frayer un chemin il y a déjà beaucoup de
monde pour l'instant aussi sur le stand
de roboroc au CES alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que roboroc présente
des nouveaux produits qui vont être je
veux dire sortir vous allez voir je
donai les dates au long de l'année et
puis ce qui va être super intéressant
durant live et bien c'est qu'il y a un
cadeau à venir gagner alors je vous
l'annonce tout de suite on le fera
gagner le live va durer à peu près 30 à
40 minutes le cadeau que vous allez
gagner c'est un aspirateur robot que je
vais vous présenter suivez bien le live
parce que la question elle va poser sur
le un des produits que je vais vous
présenter le produit à gagné ça
s'appelle le Q Revo max V qui est un
nouveau aspirateur robot de roboroc donc
restez bien connecté alors faire un tour
du stand vous montrer un peu les
nouveautés et on va commencer par une
gamme qui est vraiment cool c'est la
gamme S8 avec des nouveaux produits on
va avoir deux nouvelles références ici
la première référence c'est celui-là
c'est le S8 max ultra le S8 max ultra il
est très cool c'est le premier produit
qu'on va garder et après il y a son
deuxième produit son grand frère qui est
là c'est le Head suite max V ultra alors
vous allez voir il a deux docs de
différents un doc qui est un peu plus
petit Vous allez comprendre pourquoi et
un doc un peu plus grand je vous
explique tout dans quelques instants
alors regardez moi le premier truc qui
m'intéresse c'est celui-là le S8 max
ultra alors on va venir le regarder et
le poser regardez venez là jusque là le
S8 max ultra il est très sympa parce
qu'il a plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités regardez on va venir le
retourner la première grosse nouveauté
qu'il a et bien c'est sur la brosse
qu'on va avoir ici alors on connaît tous
la brosse qui vient tourner et qui
ramène des cochonnerie directement à
l'intérieur ici avec les brosses en
caoutchou qui vont venir tourner pour
ramener ça à l'intérieur mais lui il a
une particularité cool c'est que vous
voyez c'est qu'il peut venir s'étendre
et ce qui fait qu'en fait il va venir
vraiment nettoyer les coins très très
facilement là où avant et bien votre
aspirateur il lui manquit certains
petits coins lui il va venir faire le
taf jusqu'au bout donc ça c'est la
grosse innovation la grosse nouveauté et
la différence que vous allez avoir avec
la série Q qu'on va regarder tout à
l'heure c'est que là vous avez deux
brosses cont rotativ qui va tout vous
ramasser et tout vous mettre à
l'intérieur donc ça c'est quand même le
premier point et ça c'est quand même
génial donc ça c'est vraiment le
première grosse innovation et puis
deuxième point qui est intéressant aussi
voyez pour venir nettoyer les coins
c'est que vous avez ce petite extension
de serpilière qu'on vient retrouver
également ici et qui va faire le taf
pour venir nettoyer les coins donc une
fois de plus vous êtes tranquille et ça
ça marche bien alors autre détail et pas
des c'est ce que vous allez retrouver
ici c'est ce qu'il s' appppelle le vibre
race 3.0 en fait c'est une serpillère
qui va venir vibrer je vais vous dire
comme vous ne pourriez-vous jamais
vibrer 4000 fois par minute vous avez
deux modules de vibration en fait qui
sont intégrés directement à l'intérieur
ça permettra de venir vraiment nettoyer
le sol en profondeur donc ça c'est
vraiment un point qui est extrêmement
fort et qui est génial autre détail et
non des moindres et bien votre
aspirateur une fois qu'il a fini le
boulot il revient à la station ça va
venir nettoyer d'ici votre serpilière ça
vient nettoyer à l' cha et ça vient une
fois que ça nettoyé ça l'a séché ça la
sèche pourquoi et bien tout simplement
pour éviter les odeurs de moisissure
comme ça vous êtes tranquille vous êt
peinard alors vous parla il y a quelques
instants de ce petit bras qui vient
sortir et bien regardez je vais vous
montrer il nous faut une démo sur le
stand de robor qui est génial où on le
voit effectivement venir s'étendre et on
comprend comment marche le système on l'
ici là alors là h voyez il vient
s'étendre en fait il vient se relever ça
montre vraiment comment il vient
chercher dans les coins chose qui
faisait pas avant donc ça il le fait
comme ça et je trouve ça moi extrêmement
pratique et extrêmement malin je regarde
alors autre point de qui est très
important chez sur les aspirateurs de
roboroc c'est que la petite serpilllière
qui à l'arrière et bien elle va venir en
plus se soulever parce que là
typiquement si vous regardez par terre
vous allez voir qu'on est sur une
moquette et sur une moquette si vous
avez des tapis chez vous on veut pas que
votre serpillère Vienne frotter dessus
c'est pas terrible donc ça vient la
relever mais ça la relève très très haut
ça c'est quand même un P qui est aussi
super super cool ça la monte de 20 mm
c'est assez haut avant c'était 5 ce qui
fait que par moment si vous avez des
tapis à poil long ça pouvait frotter là
ça frotte plus c'est quand même le truc
est super important ça nettoya également
mieux le tapis avec une collecte des
poils supérieur à 30 % donc si vous
perdez vos poils ou que vos bêtes
perdent vos poils bah oui je pense à Léo
derrière qui lui va perdre ses poils et
bien c'est quand même plutôt pas mal 30
% de plus par rapport au S7 c'est un
point qui est extrêmement important
voilà donc et puis après vous avez
toutes les technologies de
reconnaissance des objets on peut venir
le voir avec les démos que vous avez ici
ils sont en train tourner alors il nous
le montre avec un petit chien qu'on va
avoir au milieu avec des chaussures avec
pas mal de petites choses et bien ça
c'est uniquement sur le S8 max V ultra
vous avez de la reconnaissance
d'obstacle avec à la fois une
reconnaissance en 3D avec une caméra RGB
qui fait le taf ça c'est vachement bien
alors il y a également une
reconnaissance d'obstacle sur le S8 max
ultra que je vous montrer on va regarder
tout de suite le deuxième modèle qui est
un peu plus haut de gamme qui en fera un
peu plus alors venez voir on va
retourner là-bas directement au niveau
des docs pour le voir on va Esser de
frer notre parce que il y a quand même
pas mal de monde ok excuse donc regardez
le premier c'était le S8 max ultra qu'on
a regardé ici là vous avez le deuxième
modèle c'est le S8 max V ultra alors le
S8 max V ultra il faut le retourner pour
voir hop là vous avez toujours le même
système ici mais on va voir une
différence qui va se faire si je vient
regarder je vous le disais par rapport à
la reconnaissance des objets vous avez
en plus un lidard hop là qui va se
situer juste en haut une caméra lidar
qui va permettre de reconnaître vos
pièces de venir cartographier donc ça
c'est quand même vachement bien toujours
la même technologie de base qu'on va
retrouver sur les deux modèles avec la
vibration au niveau de votre serpillère
avec la technologie vibra rise 3.0 avec
4000 vibration 4000 fois par minute ça
c'est aussi un point qui est extrêmement
important alors là vous me direz euh
monsieur Greux et je vous comprends il y
a un tout petit doc pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a un tout petit doc ici et bien
en fait il y a un tout petit doc mais
c'est plus destiné au marché asiatique
en fait et bien tout simplement parce
que si vous regardez ce doc là il y a
pas de de de recharge d'eau propre et un
collecteur d'eau sale ici vous venez
vous brancher directement dans votre
intérieur sur vos évacuations et sur une
arrivée d'eau ce qui permet bien de
réduire drastiquement la taille et de
venir le passer sous un meuble donc ça
c'est un point qui est extrêmement fort
mais c'est pas trop destiné à l'Europe
plus pour l'Europe nous on va avoir un M
un produit comme celui-là avec un
collecteur d'eauale avec et bien une
arrivée d'eau propre ici et avec ensuite
ici et bien votre sac qui va être juste
là donc c'est quelque chose d'un peu
plus gros un peu plus important mais qui
pour autant fera tout aussi bien le taf
et ça c'est un point très très cool
alors je regarde s'il y a pas des choses
que j'ai oublié de vous dire ah si un
point super important qu'on navait pas
Achan et qui vient d'arriver c'est écrit
juste ici c'est un assistant vocal
intelligent qui s'appelle hello Rocky
donc vous vous arrivez vous vous dites
he hello Rocky et vous lui dites ben va
nettoyer telle pièce va fais nettoyage
de la maison et ce qui est bien c'est
qu'en fait vous pouvez l'utiliser sans
Wii localement direct donc ça c'est
quand même un point extrêmement
important parce que si le wifi
fonctionne pas vous voulez pas le mettre
au wiici et ça on peut le faire
directement comme ça donc ça c'est une
grosse nouveauté c'est génial alors le
looroki on l'a uniquement sur le gros
modèle le S8 max V ultra on l'a pas sur
l'autre modèle mais bon voyez on voit
que c'est une ho qui arrive chez robor
ça c'est plutôt pas mal après il faut
savoir qu' sont quand même pilotables
avec Amazon Alexa avec Siri avec Google
home et que vous avez également le
protocole mateur qui peut être utilisé
donc ça pour tout ce qui est
connectivité on aime énormément un
widget également pour smartphone j'adore
utiliser des widgets ça c'est cool et il
y a également une application pour Apple
watch donc si vous avez comme moi une
Apple watch au poer voyez vous pouvez le
mettre vous êtes tranquille alors il y a
une autre petite fonctionnalité sur le
S8 max V ultra c'est que vous avez une
caméra comme vous avez une caméra RGB et
bien on peut faire des appels vidéos
avec pas forcément dédiés pour mais si
vous voulez faire un peu de vidéos
surveillance voir où sont vos bas
animaux lorsque vous partez et bien vous
pouvez le faire il y a une
reconnaissance des animaux également que
je trouve super bien et puis il y a une
technologie sur le S8 max B ultra
celui-là une F plus le plus gros des
deux qui va aspérer plus fort dans les
environnements où il y a des animaux il
sait que potentiellement va y avoir des
poils plus de salissure et lui va faire
le taf donc ça c'est quand même super
cool et puis bien évidemment comme sur
tous les produits de roboroc
l'application la cartographie les
nogozones où Onira pas les routines et
on peut le piloter entièrement ici donc
ce produit là ces produits là je trouve
super cool alors je vous donne tarif
quand même pour le savoir j'ai les
tarifs en dollars je les ai pas en euros
il faut déjà savoir que ces deux
produits vont arriver en avril 2024 ce
le S8 max ultra qu'on a là-bas roboroc
nous annonce un tarif en dollar à
1599,99 une fois de plus j'ai pas le
tarif en euros et le plus gros qu'on a
ici avec le gros doc le S8 max V ultra
1799,99 € alors si vous avez pas ces
budgets là et bien vous avez un autre
produit la série Q qui est aussi super
intéressante avec toutes les
fonctionnalités qui nous intéressent
regarde ez ça se passe ici Q Revo max V
ça c'est le premier modèle qu'on va
venir retrouver et puis vous avez un
deuxième modèle Pro qui situe juste là
c'est le Q Revo pro alors on va regarder
tout ça pour vous le présenter alors à
la différence des autres produit sur
celui-là si vous le prenez regardez hop
là ça se passe de l'autre côté et bien
ici vous allez voir que vous allez pas
avoir le la Flex arm qui vient bouger
ici c'est le patin à l'arrière qui vient
se déplacer c'est lui là qui va venir
faire le et qui en réalité va venir sur
l'extérieur pour venir nettoyer tous les
recoins de votre pièce voyez quand il
vient faire le coin du mur il vient
vraiment nettoyer les recoins parce que
si vous étiez comme ça il y a un moment
bah il peut pas bien nettoyer
correctement donc lui il vient il fait
le taf il se décale il nettoie et quand
il est au milieu d'une pièce il sait
forcément grâce à son système de
cartographie et bien il se repositionne
là vous êtes tranquille la différence
avec la série site c'est que vous avez
une seule brosse en caoutchou vous avez
pas double brosse ultra rotative donc
bon il en fera un petit peu moins mais
globalement ici fait quand même très
très bien le boulot il y a aucun
problème que vous dire d'autrre
également sur ce produit et bien vous
avez une puissance d'aspiration de 7000
Pascal ce qui est quand même extrêmement
performant extrêmement puissant faut
savoir que sur les deux autres sur la
série S8 vous aviez jusqu'à 10000 Pascal
que je vous dise pas de bêtises je
vérifie 10000 Pascal sur le S8 max V
ultra et le S8 max ultra é déjà à 8000
Pascal là on tombe à 7000 Pascal mais
pour faire le nettoyage de votre
intérieur
ça va franchement ça va il y a de quoi
faire donc ça c'est quand même un point
extrêmement fort
euh que vous dire de plus ça je vous
l'ai dit alors oui double serpillère à
l'arrière les serpillères elles vont
remonter également quand elles arrivent
sur des tapis et elles vont remonter
jusqu'à 10 mm elles vont pas remonter
comme les autres jusqu'à du 20 mm mais
déjà 10 mm globalement c'est plutôt
plutôt très très bien le doc que vous
allez avoir alors vous avez deux docs
différents on a ce doc là là avec et
bien toutes les parties où on peut avoir
là c'est la partie où vous allez avoir
vos salissur vous le voyez la petite
icône sur le dessus et vous avez votre
partie ici avec votre eau propre vous
venez la vider régulièrement et la
remplir également mais il vous dira dans
l'application comme ça vous êtes
tranquille et puis il y a également cet
autre module qui est plus une fois de
plus destiné à l'Asie mais qui j'espère
arrivera chez nous parce que je trouve
ça génial vous venez le mettre sur le
système d'évacuation pour enlever tout
ce qui va être salissû vous faites
arriver directement des canalisations de
l'eau propre comme ça vous réduisez
l'encombrement et ce qui est très cool
regardez je vous le montre parce que là
il vous le mettre là ça permet venir le
positionner sous un meuble et je trouve
ça une fois de plus vraiment bien parce
que ça vient éviter d'avoir des des des
éléments un peu trop gros et un peu trop
proïinant et un peu trop un peu massif
donc ça c'est cool ça arrivera ça arrive
voyez déjà là peut-être sur le marché
européen un peu plus tard en tout cas il
y a l'innovation et ça ça nous plaît
beaucoup euh qu'est-ce que je vous ai
pas ah oui venez voir LEC truc qui est
vraiment vraiment cool regardez on va
venir se positionner juste ici et bien
sur ce doc pareil il y a tout le système
de nettoyage qu'on va venir retrouver
ici avec nettoyage des sa pierres
lorsqu'elles ont été mouillées qu'elles
ont tourné on a besoin effectivement et
bien de venir les nettoyer déjà on vient
les nettoyer à l' chaude avec une e
chaude à 60° comme ça au moins vous êtes
sûr que tout ce qui va être incrusté ça
va partir et une fois qu'elle a été
nettoyée en fin de séchage bien évident
enfin en fin de nettoyage bien
évidemment bien viendra le sécher à
l'air chaud à 45°r ça c'est ce que vous
allez retrouver ici alors bon vous vous
le voyez pas normalement mais là il
vient le nettoyer et là comme ça vous
êtes totalement tranquille et vous allez
jusqu'à 7ette semaines avec un
autovidage de tout chonnerie que vous
allez retrouver normalement hop là ça se
positionne je sais pas si c'est une
trappe je sais plus comment il marche
voilà vous l'avez là vous avez un sac là
jusqu'à 7 semaines vous êtes peinard
donc ça c'est un point qui est
extrêmement important et que je trouve
aussi super cool donc vous voyez ça ça
marche et autre élément qui est très
très bien aussi et qui arrive sur cette
gamme là et bien c'est l'assistant vocal
hello Rocky que vous avez là une fois de
plus qu'on peut venir utiliser sans wifi
si on le souhaite bon ok why not on peut
venir également piloé ici comme sur
l'autre série avec Amazon Alexa avec
Siri avec Google home il y a également
le widget pour smartphone et puis
l'application pour Apple watch ça c'est
très très bien on va voir en plus alors
je regarde que sur le curevo max V pas
sur le pas sur le pro et bien vous allez
avoir la la technologie reactive ai
obstacle qui en fait va venir
reconnaître grâce à une caméra RGB et
bien les obstacles donc ça c'est très
très bien ça reconnaît 62 types d'objets
différents tenez-vous bien dans 20
catégorie donc ça c'est cool euh vous
avez par contre sur le Modelle pro une
reconnaissance d'objet grâce à ce qu'ils
appelleront la lumière structurée on n
pas de caméra en fait un peu plus
classique on a également un lidar pour
la cartographie de la maison c'est
vraiment génial et puis bien évidemment
sur ce modèle là comme vous avez une
caméra on peut venir voir ce qui se
passe à la maison faire un peu de
surveillance voir où sont les animaux je
trouve ça cool et a bien évidemment en
plus un un mode qui est totalement
optimisé pour le le nettoyage des tapis
et puis comme l'autre modèle une
cartographie qui va se faire dans
l'application les nogozones les routes e
donc voilà c'est un modèle qui ce sont
deux modèles que je trouve vraiment
intéressant dans cette cette nouvelle
gamme qui vient d'arriver on connaissait
la gamme Q là c'est CEVO qui vient
d'arriver là c'est le max V alors je
vous le dis tout de suite parce que on
va le faire gagner dans quelques
instants on va faire gagner un curevo
max V dans quelques instants c'est
celui-là ce modèle là qu'on va pouvoir
avoir donc j'espère que vous avez bien
écouté vous avez bien tout noté parce
que la question va porter sur un des
modèles peut-être sur celui-là attention
je vous aideris si vois que vous séchez
un peu c'est un peu la galère je
regarder bah ouais forcément je vais
vous aider l'idée c'est c'est quand même
que vous repartez avec un joli cadeau il
y aura un seul gagnant ou une seule
gagnante il en auras pas deux
malheureusement mais c'est déjà très
très bien et vous allez avoir toutes vos
chances ici alors c'est sont deux
produits le curevo max V et le curevo
pro qui seront disponibles au mois
d'avril 2024 alors les tarifs je vous
donne en dollars je les ai pas en euros
une fois de plus mais on les aura
prochainement et puis je vous invite à
venir je vous mets le lien dans quelques
instants parce qu'on a eu un plantage en
début de Live donc je vais vous remettre
tous les liens ensuite dans la
description le live sera en replay vous
allez pouvoir venir le regarder vous
saurez tout et bien vous allez avoir le
curevo pro qui sera à
999,99 € et le kururevo max V à
1199,99 € pardon dollars excusez-moi son
des tarifs en dollars 99999 dollars pour
le qevo pro et
1199,99 dollars pour le qevo maxv je
vous remets tout à la fin du live dans
la description comme ça vous saurez tous
les liens vous pourrez aller voir
directement sur le site de roboroc donc
ça c'est sont pour ces deux nouveaux
produits alors il y a aussi deux
nouveaux produits qui sont également
qui sont planqué derrière alors on va
venir jeter un petit coup d'œil venez
voir c'est par ICI suivez-moi c'est la
gamme Flexi et la gamme Flexi elle est
aussi cool avec deux produits différents
on va avoir le Flexy light qui situe
juste là et puis on va avoir le Flexi
pro qui est ici alors on va changer de
crèmerie pour en savoir un peu plus on
passe dans les coulissesz suivez-moi on
va par derrière on va par là hop là
comme ça je vous rentre dans les
coulisses du stand vous découvrez tout
directement chez chez roboroc ça se
passe ici alors hop
sorry regardez on va voir ces euh ces
deux produits alors le premier produit
c'est le Light le Light il est
intéressant pourquoi pour plusieurs
choses déjà ce qui est très très cool
c'est que si vous venez enlever ça vous
allez voir que sur cette partie-là vous
allez vraiment arriver quasiment à
bordure de nettoyage sur le modèle light
le Modelle Pro vous allez voir qu'il
fera des deux côtés de l'autre côté on
va pas le faire ça c'est la différence
un peu entre les deux modèles il faut
forcément des différences ici mais hop
là je mets dans l'autre sens qui reste
quand même très bien donc ça c'est pour
le model light et puis on a le model pro
on va venir faire une démo on est en
train de mettre ça par terre partout ne
faites pas ça chez vous ne mettez pas
des cochonneries mais on va pouvoir le
faire ici alors juste pour vous resituer
un petit peu les produit ça permet de
faire un nettoyage à sec ou un nettoyage
humide ils vont avoir en plus ce qu'ils
appelleent la technologie direct Smart
sensor qui va venir ajuster la puissance
et le niveau d'eau en fonction des
salissures donc ça vient reconnaître
c'est intelligent et ça monte surtout
jusqu'à 10 7000 Pascal de puissance
d'aspiration c'est très très très
puissant ça permet en plus de venir
nettoyer sous les meubles on va vous
faire la démo on peut vraiment venir
coucher nettoyer sous les meubles les
coins près des murs tout ça à moins d'un
mm alors sur le modèle light d'un seul
côté sur le modèle Pro le Flexi pro on
fait des deux côtés c'est quand même
super bien on a également un nettoyage
ça vient nettoyer ensuite pardon
excusez-moi votre brosse ici à l'eau
tiède à 60° pour éviter de garder des
salissure un séch l' chauffer après pour
venir la sécher pour éviter les odeurs
moisissur à 55°g donc ça c'est quand
même vachement bien et et puis lors du
nettoyage le nouveau le rouleau surtout
ici faut savoir que il est lavé lors du
déplacement pour avoir une propreté
maximale donc comme ça on joue vraiment
la propreté c'est intelligent c'est bien
ça nous plaît vous allez jusqu'à un
nettoyage de 60 minutes en autonomie ici
avec le Light et 30 minutes avec le
modèle Pro que je vous montre dans
quelques instants et puis vous avez un
écran tactile qu'on va retrouver juste
ici pour voir l'autonomie qui vous reste
vous venez de piloter directement et
puis vous avez en plus une application
uniquement sur le modèle professionnel
et puis l'alerte vocale on fait une
petite démo sur le sur le
Flexx on va faire une petite démo surx
aprè on sur le
flex comme çaz on est en direct on
regarde directement on se met dans le
bain donc là c'est le Flexy donc voyez
en fait en terme de manipulation ça se
lance directement vous contrôlez votre
écran là vous avez un liide vousvez
solide il passe directement dessus et il
va faire le taf en un seul coup vous
êtes peinard donc ça c'est quand même un
point qui est extrêmement important donc
en terme de de gain de nettoyage à la
maison on s'embête plus on est peinard
donc ça c'est le Flexy light et vous
avez le modèle Pro qui est juste
derrière et qui est en train d'arriver
voilà regardez hop là il est
pratique ça ça me
plaît voilà on peut passer sous les
meubles comme ça ça c'est le point qui
est aussi super intéressant vous le
baissez vous le glissez sous les meble
vous êtes pénard donc ça c'est le modèle
light ça c'est le modèle professionnel
la différence Léo viens voir ici hop la
différence c'est qu'ici vous allez
vraiment arriver voyez avec 1 mm de
chaque côté donc on vraiment nettoyer
les bordures d'un côté et de l'autre
comme ça vous êtes vraiment vraiment
peinard et c'est super super pratique on
peut passer sous les meubles également
de la même manière et puis nettoyer là
ce qui nous reste de trois petit truc
vous passez un coup vous êtes peinard
c'est vachement bien alors c'est un
produit sont de produits pardon qui
seront disponibles au deuxème semestre
2024 j'ai pas encore tout de suite la
date j'ai pas non plus encore tout de
suite les tarifs mais ça va arriver donc
on prend un peu son mal en patience une
fois de plus je vous mets tous les liens
enfin je vous les mettre dans quelques
instants tous les liens dans thank you
very much tous les liens dans la
description ça va arriver donc je vous
les mets sur replay vous les verrez ils
y seront directement donc voyez sont des
produits qui sont vraiment cool on voit
une fois de plus qu' a toute cette
innovation qui est au cœur qui est dans
l'ADN de roboroc sur les différents
produits je voulais vous monrer un peu
la démo est-ce que les aspirateurs sont
en train train de tourner là-bas ou pas
où ils sont en repos alleer savooir un
peu mes lapins non il est dans ils sont
dans leur doc là donc voyez ils sont on
est fatigué on se pose un petit peu donc
il y a vraiment ces trois gammes de
produits à dire retenir pour l'instant
chez chez roboroc on en reparlera sur la
chaîne parce que une fois de plus je
suis affici dos et j'utilise les
produits de roborque à la maison on
retient bien dans la gamme S on a le S8
max ultra le S8 max V ultra qui sont
deux produits super cool on y retourne
on va regarder un peu vite fait la
différence pour se faire un petit résumé
hop là on se frille en chemin c'est ça
le ces il y a du monde il y a des allées
de tous les
côtés hop là on passe par là regardez
suivez-moi ça se passe juste ici et
ouais les joies du
direct donc ces deux produits là qui
vont réellement être être être
différents avec le Flexi arm qui va
venir bouger pour venir ramasser toutes
les cochonneries qui sont vraiment le
long des murs ça c'est vraiment la
grosse techno avec une très grosse
puissance d'aspiration qu'on VI retenir
ici sur ce produit là une fois de plus
allerchet sur le site de Rob parce que
c'est vachement bien on a ensuite par
ici l'autre produit Q Revo max V Q Revo
pro où là c'est plus le flex arm qui
bouge mais c'est le patin arrière en
nettoyage qui va venir bouger également
avec d'un côté et de l'autre et bien
l'arrivée de l'assistant intelligent
éoroki qu'on retrouve chez roboroc qui
est vachement bien avec tout plein de
techno que je vous ai cité tout à
l'heure avec une très grosse puissance
d'aspiration également et puis hop là on
sfille encore un petit chemin par
derrière on le voitve avec les roboc les
flexil light les Flexi pro qui sont ici
donc il y a vraiment ces trois gammes
qui sont extrêmement intéressantes et
qu'on retrouve pour l'instant tout de
suite chez chez roboroc alors jete un
petit coup d'œil vite fait à vos
questions avant de passer au concours
parce que je sais que vous êtes là pour
avoir un cadeau qui est beau et vous
avez raison et moi ça me fait plaisir je
reprends rapidement je remonte un petit
peu le fil il y a eu beaucoup de
messages merci à tous d'être là j'ai la
flemme de passer l'aspi ça fait
énormément de bruit ben franchement
avoir un bon aspirateur c'est très très
important à la
maison je regarde un peu avec tac tac
tac tac
tac tac tac tac date de 6e trimestre sur
les flexis mais ça on verra un peu plus
tard hop là il a deux brosses comme sur
le diad regardez en fait vous le voyez
on va regarder le pro ici hop là vous
avez une seule brosse le diad c'est un
peu la différence des gammes c'est que
sur le diad vous avez deux brosses ici
vous avez une seule brosse mais par
contre voyez on vient vraiment le long
avec ce côté de 1 mm pour venir nettoyer
vraiment je veux dire très très près des
murs c'est quand même vraiment vraiment
génial donc ça c'est vraiment le point
fort il y a une différence he faut bien
qu'il une différence de gamme entre côté
flexible côté diad il viennent rajouter
en profondeur de gamme don ça c'est
aussi le le point extrêmement
extrêmement important voilà un peu pour
tout toutes ces tous ces petits messages
alors on va passer au concours et ouais
alors je vais vous remontrer le modèle
qu'on va gagner dans quelques instants
que je vais vous faire gagner c'est pas
moi qui va gagner c'est vous que je vous
fais gagner c'est le curevo max V le
curevo max V et bien c'est ce modèle
là-bas le grand blanc qu'on a juste ici
voyez c'est celui-là là celui-là
celui-là on va le gagner alors il y a un
petit concours alors j'espère que vous
avez été attentif et que vous avez tout
regarder comme ça vous saurez réellement
ça parle de tous les côtés alors ce
produit je vous donne la question
regardez est-ce que vous êtes prêts
est-ce que vous avez bien écouté j'ai
une question regardez je me décage un
peu derrière ça un peu plus de calme
voilà parce qu'il y a beaucoup de monde
les gens sont tous venus voir le stand
de roboroc directement la question est
la suivante accrochez-vous bien quelle
est la puissance
d'aspiration de la gamme Flexi alors je
vous l'ai dit il y a quelques instants
comme ça si vous avez eu le temps de
noter et si vous savez pas et bien je
vous donnerai un petit indice allez je
regarde le premier ou la première qui
répond et bien on va regarder hello
hello 7000 7000 non c'est pas 7000 c'est
pas 7000 pour la gamme Flexi on parle
bien
duention le Flexi c'est le grand qu'on a
et qu'on peut venir bouger directement à
la main la puissance d'aspiration je
regarde 14000 kg non vous y êtes pas ah
nous avons souvd qui nous le donne bravo
s vous tu es le premier ou la première
pardon je ne sais pas à mettre la bonne
réponse donc c'est toi qui gagne en
rapidité qui a bien suivi 17000 kg
Pascal on est c'est pas c'est pas 17000
kil Pascal ah c'est 17000 Pascal ça
serait 17 kg Pascal je vais pas faire
mon pas faire mon SAL allez c'est toi
qui REP ce qu'il faut que tu me fasses
pour valider ton gain tu me fais une
capture d'écran tout de suite du chat
une capture d'écran de ton profil
YouTube et tu m'envoies un mail tu
m'envoie un mail à l'adresse hello
h2l@ monsieur en entier m o n s i e u R
grrrmsieurg tout en entier.fr
hello@asmieurg.fr tu mis bien les
captures d'écran pour qu'on voit bien
que c'est toi directement et tu
m'envoies ton adresse ton numéro de
téléphone pour que roboroc puisse
t'envoyer ton lot extrêmement rapide
ridement voilà félicitations bravo c'est
cool on a le ou la gagnante je sais pas
si c'est le ou la gagnante on peut
féliciter quand même parce que je sais
que vous étiez plusieurs à vouloir
l'avoir mais bon c'est comme ça
malheureusement jeis bien avoir plus de
de lot à gagner mais he c'est déjà très
très bien donc ça c'est cool donc voilà
pour ces nouveautés qu'on retrouve
directement sur le stand de roboroc au
CES 2024 on retient vraiment ces trois
nouvelles gammes pas trois nouvelles S8
famille de produits la série Q Revo qui
est nouvelle la série Flexi qui est
nouvelle les S8 max ultra et S8 max V
ultra qui sont des évolutions de la
gamme qu'on connaissait déjà avant mais
qui sont aussi tout aussi bien et super
intéressants une fois de plus dans
quelques instants je vais vous remet
tous les liens juste en bas dans la
description puisqu'on a eu ce petit
problème de lancement de live mais bon
on est là et c'est quand même le plus
important voilà je regarde si j'ai rien
oublié parce que c'est quand même un peu
dommage de pas tout vous dire mais
normalement on est bon vous avez toutes
les infos on a vu beaucoup de choses
c'était dan en information on en
reparlera cette année très probablement
de ces produits pour rentrer plus en
détail et voir un peu les usages chez
vous de quelle manière il fonctionneent
vous montrer C Flexi arm ça j'ai
vraiment hâte de le tester parce que qui
viennent vraiment nettoyer récupérer sur
les côtés des cochonneries c'est des
fois le les défaut mais un peu la limite
de certains produits qui viennent
récupérer ce qui se passe dans les
recoins ça botte énormément voilà donc
merci à vous d'avoir été très nombreus
et très nombreux à avoir suivi ce live
sur Youtube je vous mets une fois de
plus dans quelques instants tous les
liens dans la description allez jeter un
œil merci à vous d'avoirt éit là d'avoir
répondu au rendez-vous nous on va
continuer le salon c'est le matin vous
je sais qu'il est un petit peu tard nous
il est 11h du math on va continuer c'est
cool voilà je vous embrasse prenez soin
de vous et puis à très bientôt des
bisous ciao oh là là rege-moi cette fin
c'est Hollywood c'est Hollywood ici
c'est Hollywood bravo alors là Léo c'est
pire qu'à Hollywood
là allez merci à vous d'avoir été
extrêmement nombreus extrêmement
nombreux euh voilà et puis on peut
ensuite venir raccrocher en appuyant sur
le petit bouton si tu vois mon petit lot
le petit bouton hop là la petite croix
on ferme et bisous à bientôt